all-time favorite comedian and also
other favorite comedians okay I have um
Bonnie McFarland who I just mentioned
so funny one of the funniest people I
watched her we were in
um in Texas together and I cried after
her set it was so good wow I was just
like I'm so glad you're my friend
um Dave Attell
um still love Louie you can't I mean the
[ __ ] can't stop being so [ __ ]
funny
um
who else
uh do you feel like you've lost any
respect for him were you kind of like
hey that was a chapter in your life well
that it's
ah how do you even deal with that
because you guys it's just such a weird
well
I mean like I've opened for him since
all that went down he did not try to
[ __ ] me
rude Louie um no it's gross
I wish I didn't know any of that
don't you wish you could just be not
woke you're like I want to be not woke
yeah it's like you're such a great guy I
didn't know but I don't know I don't you
know I just I guess I look at that
as a mistake and for me well
I think the thing everyone gets mad
about is maybe the way he sounds very
arrogant the way he like wrote the
apology but I he wrote things in the
apology that made me like under like
articulated things I felt before that I
never he said something about like where
he's like when I thought I was
presenting them with a question I was
actually presenting them with a
predicament
and that is how I felt a lot of times
so I don't know it's just right other
comedians
um
I mean there's so much old school old
school
Carol Burnett
I mean I love Joan Rivers
she was kind of old school she just
croaked I was watching her special I
will say this like as I'm sort of like
in hypnosis I'm sort of like creating
what like what do I want to be right
like where do I want to go and I am
sorry to say this guys I am going to
Lady Gaga this [ __ ] sorry [ __ ] I'm
going big
um but
um I do like I've been watching all
these documentaries of like powerful
women not just women powerful men and
people that have inspired me throughout
my life
and she was so unhappy when I watched
Joan Rivers documentary it made me so
sad she was so seeking the approval of
like the outside world when it was like
she did have it it's just she was only
looking at the people that weren't
giving it to her right and so for me
like I take from her
like the part from her that I'm taking
when I'm creating the like you know
future Annie
Rising risen star
um I take from her that she was always
funny yeah she was I mean I wasn't I'm
move very serious on the spot guys but
but you know she just always took she
always went for the joke and I just love
that she's always being funny